you do not even have to have elections
anymore because you can already
predict what predict and afterwards you
can say why do we need elections hey
guys I'm off the grid for August but you
know who doesn't take any time off for
August it's evil globalist leader Klaus
Schwab so technology now is and digital
Technologies mainly have an analytical
power now we go into a predictive power
and we have seen the first examples and
your company very much involved into it
but since the next step could be in to
go into a prescriptive
a mode which means
[Music]
you you do not even have to have
elections anymore because you can
already
predict what uh predict and afterwards
you can say why do we need elections
because we know what the result will be
can you imagine such a world foreign